hey you checking out my ride this tumblr
sparrows just the beginning I get all my
sweetest loot down there deep within the
dark below see this this is the necro
chasm fires 900 rounds a minute it's
sexy cuz it's dangerous and check out
this helmet pure and chromium sir
chromium whatever it ends at him it
really doesn't matter just look me in
the eyes and tell me this is not awesome
and it's lined with like soak or
something so there's no chafing even
when you're going ham on some high boom
daddy's home pro tip the dark blows got
news story missions crucible maps a
fresh strike and other stuff so new I'm
not even supposed to talk about this is
new that's new this is trota he's new
wait is that a jacuzzi call me when you
level up bro there's even a new range
but you here
pull the rarest Lou get in and just milk
that sucker hard because there's exotic
and then there's this dragons breath
this is like a sasquatch in the Unicorn
had a baby exotic I didn't get to
something else ticking okay maybe some
other stuff but not this ah smells like
baking and bloodshed wardrobe change
nothing says I just hit level 32 like
these they're called radiant dance
machine huh sexy
pappadeaux you want it huh get it good
meow want to earn legendary gear like
this get set up with missions from eros
on the tower yeah you may look like
trouble but when does that ever stopped
you before you don't even have to be
level 30 to get in ah but it couldn't
hurt it's like I'm saying you want to
level up you gotta go below see you
you